schwarze löcher stellen uns immer noch
vor große rätsel besonders faszinierend
aber gleichzeitig rätselhaft sind die
sogenannten strahlungs jets das sind
gigantische materiestrahl quasi heiße
gas fontänen die von schwarzen löchern
ins weltall gefeuert werden bisher
wusste man nur dass die vorgänge ihrer
entstehung komplexer und sehr gewaltig
sind jetzt ist einem britischen
forschungsteam das unvorstellbare
gelungen einen blick mitten in das
innenleben dieser jets wie das genau
funktioniert hat und was uns dieses
forschungsergebnis für das verständnis
von schwarzen löchern bedeutet jetzt bei
klicks und science fiction herzlich
willkommen sich ein genaues bild von
einem schwarzen loch zu machen ist gar
nicht so einfach alles was ihnen zu nahe
kommt wird verschluckt vorher aber
sammelt sich die materie in der
sogenannten akkretionsscheibe einer
schnell rotierenden scheibe und genau
diese akkretionsscheibe schießt
gigantische materie strahlen aus vielen
schwarzen löchern heraus senkrecht nach
oben und unten ins all
und das sind die sogenannten jets die
man sich tatsächlich vorstellen kann wie
fontaine forschungsteams vermuten schon
seit längerem dass die jets wohl aus
nickel und eisen bestehen und mit
unglaublichen 200.000 kilometern pro
sekunde ins all schießen
das sind zwei drittel der
lichtgeschwindigkeit unklar dagegen wie
genau entsteht ein solcher jet warum
wird ein teil der materie reflektiert
und senkrecht ins all geschossen
jetzt ist einem forschungsteam von der
universität southampton aus
großbritannien ein spektakulärer
einblick in diese rätselhafte materie
strahlen gelungen möglich wurde das
durch den röntgen satelliten new star
der nasa und mit hilfe von teleskopen
auf der erde
sie interessierten sich bei ihrem
untersuchungen vor allem für die
helligkeit ausbrüche in zwei systemen
der milchstraße hier stoppten sie die
exakte zeit und stellten dabei fest die
ausbrüche sind zunächst im
röntgenbereich zu sehen er ist eine
zehntel sekunde später im sichtbaren
bereich des lichts und das britische
forschungsteam hat auch eine erklärung
dafür schnelle teilchen in der nähe des
schwarzen lochs strahlen die
röntgenstrahlung aus das sichtbare licht
dagegen entsteht ihrer vermutung nach
ausnehmen
jazz zwischen diesen beiden punkten
sehen sie den haupt beschleunigungs
bereich ist eine größe also die
entfernung zwischen diesen beiden
punkten ergibt ihren berechnungen nach
etwa 30.000 kilometer und das absolut
frappierende das haben beide
untersuchten systeme gemeinsam das ist
schon ziemlich verwunderlich wenn man
bedenkt dass ihre zustände und
abmessungen sehr unterschiedlich sind
doch die astronomen astronom sehen die
masse der schwarzen löcher als
entscheiden dann diese trägt dem
aktuellen forschungsergebnissen zufolge
mutmaßlich dazu bei wie groß der haupt
beschleunigungs bereich in einem solchen
jet ist heißt also konkret um so mehr
masse gegeben ist umso größer ist der
jeweilige beschleunigungs bereich dazu
einer der beteiligten forscher post an
die wir sind hoch begeistert weil es so
aussieht als hätten wir einen
charakteristischen maßstab für das
innenleben der jets gefunden dieses
ergebnis passt tatsächlich zu früheren
untersuchungen an supermassereichen
schwarzen löchern
auch hier hatten forschungsteams einen
zeitverzug festgestellt und auch hier
schlussfolgerten sie auf einen
entsprechenden größeren beschleunigungs
bereich wenn er kein video mehr zum
thema schwarze löcher und zu den
neuesten erkenntnissen dazu verpassen
wollt dann drückt man hier ein abo aufs
auge und vergesst nicht den genau auf
die glocke hier geht es weiter mit und
dafür draufklicken mysteriös schwarzes
loch wirft theorie über schwarze löcher
um und ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran